what's your takeaways from the Scouting
Combine workouts full transparency I
watched some of it on Thursday night
yeah I don't like that they move these
things to later in the day because later
in the day I got other stuff to do I've
been working all day I'm not gonna watch
these combine workouts cuz it's not
football
sorry put them on in the morning again
I'll put them on while I'm working but
I'm not making my life come to a halt on
a Friday Saturday and Sunday late
afternoon evening and late into the
evening to watch a bunch of guys running
around in their underwear I refuse to do
it Chris well I don't refuse to do it I
do like that I said nighttime you're
right all right so do you know full
transparency my mom and dad had their
40th wedding anniversary on Saturday
night with my anniversary happy
Anniversary Dirty Diana and big Phil
that's right yes but so I went there but
then it's nice to know you have a
nickname for your mom oh yeah yeah I
can't leave her at least you can at
least you can use that nickname on teeth
again I can use that one but yes so I
DVR it and then the next morning I wake
up and you know Sunday morning I sit
there and have a coffee and start eating
my breakfast and watch the combine my
big takeaway you know more than anything
I do like it being in primetime you know
I did especially Thursday and Friday
night I found that enjoyable I was just
sitting around the house not doing much
okay so that aspect of it was fun and I
guess you're recovering from come on
you're right well you're right I mean if
I if I was feeling healthy I don't know
how I would have felt on a Friday night
but either way it felt like more of a
show and an event and I think my big
takeaway would be one first off probably
this guy right here
Justin Herbert right he would be one guy
I would look at and just go wow you know
was the workout perfect no but he showed
me signs of being able to do
extraordinary things extraordinary
physical talent and the ability to make
very hard throws make it look very
normal so that would be one thing that
would jump out to me as far as the
quarterbacks wide receiver workout where
I'd go Wow hey of course we know Henry
rugs and the four to seven and all that
but the other day the other guy that I
think at that first night that would
jump out to me other than Justin Herbert
would be chase Claypool from Notre Dame
I think that would be the second guy in
my list I mean come on right Mike I mean
there's just not a lot of guys walking
around Planet Earth
Calvin Johnson right Johnson right and
you know I've seen the guy in person
over the years so I if you're talking
about two guys that I said Wow and I
think maybe improved their stock you
know those would be two right off the
bat just on that Thursday night workout
where chase Claypool he he put himself
into the position of weapon now going
forward it's not even wide receiver
because I think some people look at him
and go I think he could be a tight end
and we can move him around like that and
he's physical like that so he's gonna
have a lot of play I think going forward
and then getting into Friday let me tell
you that the guy that that was one of
the most impressive one of the most fun
to talk to the most engaging on
Wednesday Jonathan Taylor the running
back from Wisconsin to blaze a four
three nine and and how infrequent is it
that the unofficial number ends up being
right and the official number usually
the official number goes up so with four
four oh one unofficial you're bracing
for the four four four four four five
it goes to four three nine official
faster than say qualm Barkley by one
hundredths of a second the guy's 220
plus pounds he had six thousand yards
rushing in three seasons at Wisconsin
this guy's got the potential to be
something at the NFL level and he is a
great talker fun guy to talk to write
very engaging funny yes yes yes I know I
got to see a little of your interview
with him on Thursday and stuff he is
he's got a great personality about him
and you know Mike I think you would
agree that that's that's a game-changing
number for that position that will make
him be looked at in a different light
when people turn on the film you know
hey everybody knows Wisconsin running
backs everyone's a little scared every
now and then oh they a lot of wear and
tear on their tires they run the ball a
lot blah blah blah yeah I get it
but I think that is they type a number
at four thirty nine like you said at
2:26 where that is going to put him back
up into that I feel like DeAndre swift
was kind of like the leader of oh that's
the number one running back on the board
when you do what Jonathan Taylor did
that's gonna make everybody go back and
go I'm not so sure about that now well
this guy is a little more explosive than
you know I thought and gave him credit
for
right that's gonna make everybody take a
little closer look when they watch the
film you know to see if that totally
translate which I think it does and you
know it's funny I think that that speaks
to what the value of a good combine were
right out is when it's time to retreat
to the real evidence of whether or not a
guy can play football you look at him
differently you're you're you're you
you've got a positive bias back watching
the film instead of saying this guy ran
a four or five two and you're looking
for the things to be critical of now
when you're watching the film you're
looking for the things to be positive
but you are it's it changes your outlook
on the film you're right and now when he
runs away peep from people you're not
gonna go oh well was that just some you
know big ten slow linebacker now you're
gonna go Navy I don't know I don't know
who that was but I know he's fast and it
doesn't really matter anymore and when
he breaks out for 40 and 50 yard gains
you're gonna go he's a home run hitter
you know he's not just the power back so
yeah I thought those were three guys you
know in those first two nights that
really jumped out to me along with some
other ones Mike we interviewed that
Denzel Mims on Tuesday what was that
last Tuesday right the wide receiver
from Baylor he would be another guy I
would look at he told us he's you know
his Michael Thomas was his idol he told
us he was gonna run really fast he did I
mean that's another guy that I look at
and go that's a game-changing number for
somebody who's six to 215 and you run
for four flat you know no longer are you
just a really good polished oh I like
this kid receiver now you go to whoa I
can do other things with him on my
offense if your offensive coordinator or
an evaluator to go he could take off the
top of the defense we can make a whole
set of plays that are aggressive down
the field around that type of speed so
he would be one that jumps out as well a
lot of sub for for worse and just to got
under for three and how about linebacker
Isaiah Simmons we talked about him
earlier for 39 and 40 he would catch
Jonathan Taylor if he'd been one of
those linebackers in the big ten and and
you know with all these great skill
position players on offense coming into
the NFL now you get a linebacker who can
move like that
you got yourself something special yes
you do I mean and it's like okay yeah he
he's linebacker and Mike I know you
watch Clemson enough like this guy is
everywhere I mean it's it's stand up
linebacker its outside linebacker it's
Nickelback it's safety I mean he's
really got a versatility that I don't
know if I've really ever seen anybody
coming to the league with that's that's
where it's that special on defense I
think one of the negatives about him
will end up being okay a little bit like
Minka Fitzpatrick a few years ago in the
Alabama secondary it's gonna be like wow
he could play them all so good what
exactly is his position now I think
stand up linebacker will be that but yes
like chase Claypool when you're 238
pounds and you're running you know this
is 439 you know that that's that's top
10 top 12 pic material Isaiah Simmons
would that work out pretty much nailed
his spot down in the top 10 or 12 what
other big picture observations did you
make when you watch the workouts on on
see yet you kind of cheated that you
need to watch it live Christopher on it
the next morning but either way you're
watched it what else stood out well I
you know I mean a few of the different
drills I guess I would look at and go I
liked them you know I like some of the
new DB drills
I like the fadeaway they're the the
fades in the back of the end zone
type throws that the the quarterbacks
and receivers did I did I you know I
thought that in general the the
quarterback receiver route running stuff
I thought was smoother and it got
quarterbacks getting a little bit more
in a rhythm than years before where you
know I just years before it's with two
throws or one throw go to the back of
the line okay see you later
you know I felt like this year they let
them have three four throws in a row get
them in a rhythm keep it going that way
I think you have a better chance of
evaluating these quarterbacks when they
do it that way instead of just one throw
or two throws and move to the back of
the line
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports